and i feel like i'm gonna have to rewire
myself
so that when i see somebody out in the
world who's not wearing a mask i don't
instantly think you are a threat or you
are selfish or you are a covid denier
and you definitely haven't been
vaccinated
i mean we're going to have to rewire the
way that we look at each other
or you could just be normal
all right after months of sputtering
vacillation
the cdc says fully vaccinated americans
can ditch masks
and don't have to social distance in
most indoor places
unless you're in a room with andrew
cuomo in that case run
speaking of that ass even after
restrictions have been lifted he's still
being cautious
claiming to rely quote on the facts and
the science
yeah now he's careful was he relying on
the facts and the science when he sent
coven patients to rest homes
if that were facts and science then his
treatment of women were delightful acts
of chivalry
so the cdc says you could skip wearing
masks outside
in other news the cdc says women can
vote and wear pants
so i'm not sure i'm for either we're
going too fast
according to the new york times the cdc
is finally catching up to the science
it's not true they're finally catching
up to you we always knew that covet
doesn't spread outdoors it's not like
chlamydia at coachella
which i learned sadly we also knew that
vaccination was supposed to eliminate
risk of spread which was motivation for
getting it the cdc however
so obsessed with the slightest risks the
kinds that are smaller than choking to
death on soup
made their guidance as helpful as
financial advice from bernie madoff
so why did they change is it because
they've now followed the science
no because if they had followed the
science they would have come to this
conclusion a while ago
fact is they didn't follow science they
followed you
they knew that if they kept pushing the
american public too far we were gonna
push back
plus the experts knew you were right but
they couldn't admit it
and anybody married is laughing at that
right now
see all their guidance is based on fear
fear of not being wrong
but fear of being exposed why is that
well these are not leaders and how can
you tell
they played it safe that's not a leader
that's your 75 year old aunt tilly
backing out of her driveway
leaders take risks they listen to
experts but then weigh the risks
against the benefits it's like a coach
who talks to his assistants
and then goes for it on fourth down
that's a hockey reference cat
a leader must face obstacles head-on and
if they fail be willing to take the fall
as for the experts in the media the
constant covering of their asses created
an
ever-worsening feedback loop a weak
politician might accept the risks of
reopening but retreat
the moment someone tweets but people
will die
so they told you to sit tight at home
masked even if you're living with older
folks
the irony the people who yell wear a
mask or you're killing grandma
we're supporters of the biggest grandma
killers of all
and so after every time an adult
publicly assessed risk
you'd get some media asshat asking how
many people are you willing to see
die just over a month ago cdc director
rochelle walensky said
she had a sense of impending doom well
thanks for the pep talk doc
you must be great on a plane flight
fact is we accept death every day sad
but true insurance actuaries count the
future deaths we naturally accept no one
has ever been able to escape the
phenomenon of death
except keith richards leaders leaders
get that but experts don't
experts aren't paid to lead like gramps
taking a leak at 3am they're just paid
to spray their opinions all over the
place
and the american people aren't experts
they're better
think about our ancestors who came here
the opposite of a safe space
no expert was advising them to come here
like marshmallow top sweet potatoes it's
unique to america
we're number one because we won't take
number two from anyone
so we ditched the masks but why stop
there
while we're at it let's decide on other
crap that we're tired of
like those stupid little circles on the
ground
where you're supposed to stand in line i
just want to buy preparation h at
walmart
without having to play the cdc's version
of twister
and enough with bringing your disgusting
reusable bag to the store
it's got more bacteria in it than tommy
lee's hot tub
let's get back to paper or plastic and
stop charging us for it
that green new deal is all about the
green i'm afraid
seriously remember how much fun it was
to shop for food in the good old days
the smells
the colors the cereals the checker who
hates you because you once laughed at
her
i'm with her shirts the produce section
was therapeutic
sure you never bought any vegetables but
it smelled great on your way to the
freezer to grab beer and chicken nuggets
oh man in the deli section being
surrounded by all that meat
takes me back to my wrestling days and
who needs all that meat
turns out i need all that meat seriously
there are like six kinds of salami
no wonder foreigners openly weep in
front of the counter
in their shops back home the meat was
made of wood
and let's not forget the head cheese now
we know what happened to jimmy hoffa
and let's stop wiping down everything
i've never wiped so hard since that time
as a kid
when i thought ex-lax was leftover
halloween candy
that's another poop joke let's go to the
angry white veil one more time
new guidance from government officials
let me guess does it say
ignore everything we say and live your
life like a free individual
like someone who makes his own decisions
about his own life is that what it says
because
that's kind of what i've been doing you
know what
why don't we assume that's what it says
typical far right extremist now this
might sound corny
but we need to see each other's faces
even cats
we need to see smiles we've been through
a lot together
and we need to interact like human
beings like naked germans at fat camp
we need to feel free and finally let's
stop talk
taking media proclaimed experts
seriously unless it's me you can trust
me
because i'm truly an expert
actually i am an expert in nothing
except buying used leather chaps on ebay
let's welcome tonight's guests he's such
a great author he can eat alphabet soup
and poop out a bestseller
up in the air author walter turns
she's so sharp you can use her brain to
stab people
financial analyst and author of the
man's guide to corporate culture heather
zumarrogo
this man actually reads apple's terms of
service
freedom works vice president and author
of the new book when politicians
panic john tamney there he is
every day her husband tells her three
little words
what have i done [ __ ] this contributor
cat tip
walter is this the right time to stop
wearing masks or were you
were you over this a while ago what is
your whole vomit your opinion on me is
what i'm saying
okay first of all masks are gonna end
when teenagers
tell us to end them um you know when
parents
are going out for the night and they're
putting on the mask and the kid says mom
please don't
mask will be over um because they rule
the world
yeah they they rule the world and and
you know they're not going to be into
them
soon and this is going to be like a snow
melt in minnesota where the snow doesn't
melt all at once
right you know under certain trees and
rocks it stays
and they're going to be people who don't
give up their masks ever yeah
they're going to be like those people
who after presidential elections keep
the losing
bumper sticker on their car for that way
that way they can't be
they they can't be blamed for anything
that happens over the next two years
that's
not true so there's going to be people
who just like they have bernie stickers
on their subaru
are going to keep the masks in about two
and a half years from now somebody's
gonna die of covert in brazil and
they're gonna say
see exactly um you're not gonna be able
to escape the
uh a coveted outbreak or this or that
they're gonna use that your analogy is
excellent it's like the person who wears
two masks
or three masks it's just like the person
with three bumper stickers
exactly i mean there's more the better
yeah the virtue signal
yeah and so anybody who ever dies or
contracts covid
for the next five years is gonna bring
out these people who come out in their
mass and say
if you'd been like me no this would have
yeah heather um you just wrote a book on
corporate culture
how has corporate culture changed is it
changed forever
well basically there is no corporate
culture if we're all living inside our
homes
working remotely you're one of the few
that have dared to step outside
i consider myself a true american hero
where no man has gone before
thank you america no i think i deserve a
lot of applause for basically
yes thank you now you can stop
applauding stop applauding i'm you know
i
well you can applaud later all right i
think that we will have to wear a mask
as we go back to the workplace
in this new normal corporate culture um
and i hope not forever um fauci said
we'll never be able to shake hands again
and that's in the book and at the time
when i was writing it i had hoped he
would be wrong but
it may be true that that may not be
acceptable to even shake hands but he
doesn't help
matters he is such a he's such he's like
the prototypical
uh prototypical or just typical why did
i add proto to that i don't know he's
the typical bureau
bureaucrat john he's there he's not
there to lead he's there to protect his
job
right oh yeah for him there are always
going to be holdouts you look back to
the former soviet union there are still
people
who believe in stalin to this day and
wish those days were
around and that describes fauci to a t
he's never had so much attention in his
life
um he and and let's add that all this
exposes hides all the how he was wrong
so many times before we're talking about
someone who said that aids could be
passed around
just by us sitting next to each other
did he say that yeah that's in
in 1983 that was the report he wrote are
you kidding me no it doesn't indict him
that he's wrong what indicts him is that
he's been so wrong so many times yet he
continues to foist
his alarmism who's the guy that invented
pcr gary mullis carrie mills do you ever
see what he has to say about fauci he i
mean he basically says exactly what you
say that fauci
is just like how did he get this far
right
kerry mullis challenged fauci to a
debate over aids and claimed that the
pcr test could not be used to diagnose
illness
and unfortunately carrie died in
september before covet oh really um
you can fact check that but it was that
fall um
we would never have had an anthony fauci
had kerry mullis still been around he
he i don't think he's gonna last frankly
i i don't think he's gonna last as this
avatar of of of covid it was more
important to throw out the opening day
pitch
than to solve the pandemic at the time
no cat you know what's funny shouldn't
we have
a national just quit this stupid stuffed
day
yeah everybody burns their masks and it
and
uh just pick a day because to to
walter's point it's one of those things
that's like a slow melt
unless we say enough people are still
holding on they really say how
ugly are you people i don't actually
it's not
that though it's worse than that uh i i
saw a lot of very dumb
takes on twitter yesterday shockingly
dumb even as someone who watches as much
reality tv as i do
there was one woman who's a reporter
writer for the huffington post
and she was saying listen this is
horrible that this is happening
you know we should keep the mat keep the
mass in so many other countries it's not
a big deal and i am an
asian-american i want to keep wearing
the mask without feeling uncomfortable
and although she thought that she set up
that tweet in a way or you could not
disagree with her without being a racist
um it was so stupid because this isn't
another country and the difference is it
was founded on individual liberty
so you want to wear your mask knock
yourself out maybe literally even if
it's so hot outside and you're exerting
yourself at all okay
but i'm not going to and you can leave
me alone yeah
any are there any practices that are
that bother you guys that
that uh or your fear like like those
little things on the floor
piss me off um what are they called cats
they're little round the round circle
temperature taking
yeah the devil all these i mean is this
stuff all gonna go away
well i heard you were wiping milk jugs
yes up and down for a long time
so i mean that would that would bother
me if i saw that and the white being
we didn't have to wipe the jokes
well look when i'm exercising outside if
i'm not wearing a mask
just the other day and the person that
i'm passing turns and
faces a brick wall the new york times
said not
one case i know how out of a hundred and
eight but that person
would want you to know how much better
they were than you are yeah
that's really it yeah and and that's why
we're going to have trouble giving up
the masks because
they gave people the opportunity to
shame
everyone classify each other at first
sight and americans
love that we are going to move on hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else